oh i gotta go okay there's something
else you can do here in town to get you
in the holiday spirit
it's arya's winter wonderland and jc of
course stopped by to check it out let's
take a look
i feel like i need to go get a christmas
sweater because the lobby here inside
the aria hotel has been transformed into
a winter wonderland
and the centerpiece is this gigantic
sugar palace behind me
it is beautiful and the man behind it is
chef matthew
so how long does it take you guys to
make something like this
we worked on it for the last four weeks
uh me um the team of course uh
uh the team is behind this uh uh the
yeah with flowers and this wall you know
a couple thousand pounds of
sugar for the wall alone you said a
couple thousand pounds so this is one
ton of sugar here this wall right here
yep yep that is incredible now look at
the attention to detail first off i did
not do that that was here when i got
here i did not do that
but something like this how long does it
take to make this hand blown is it a
flower oh yeah the flowers are
totally probably one day those flowers
and but this one maybe a few minutes you
know to make one
now the roof the shingles is each one
hand blown yeah yeah
those are poured sugar each one
individually poured
and then sprayed it painted and you
might recognize chef matthew
from netflix's sugar high the champion
his partner andy she's on the other side
we're going to talk to her right now
about how
you guys make some of this madness chef
andy the attention to details that you
have on your sugar palace are absolutely
incredible let's talk about the
nutcrackers and what you guys did with
the nutcrackers
so here is our display window with our
five nutcrackers and our pastry team
actually
designed the three cakes that the little
nutcrackers are holding uh talk to me
about you
putting the stuff and and sticking the
stuff in the wall here of the house how
does that process work
so right now we're just going to add
some finishing touches to around the
window here
um we're going to torch some snowflakes
just heat it up that's it yep
just a little bit just enough to melt
kind of the surface
and it sticks just like it looks like
you just gotta hold it for a second
and it'll sit and how long will this
stay it'll stay
as long as someone like me doesn't knock
it off yes yes it will shatter
all right chef andy may have the honors
as we wrap up to do the final finishing
touches you can come down to the aria
hotel and see this beautiful
winter wonderland yourself and i can say
that i contributed to this gorgeous
thank you thank you so much merry
christmas thank you merry christmas
nice contribution jc